you know i did see slap i enjoyed slap i
was i was very impressed with with my
hitch you know
quite an arm on hitch i like your tugs
but right away look good feel good am i
right
keep my wife's name
man i love the oscars man during his
acceptance speech will smith said love
will make you do crazy things you know
what else makes you do crazy things
crazy saturday night live is back from
hiatus and thanks to the slap heard
around the world
oh richard
oh wow
they had no shortage of new material but
as far as the news cycle keep the news
coming please we need ideas that's what
keeps the show on
ideas abound via news so yeah i'm all
for a quick moving cycle
first up a fox and friends parody during
the cold open featuring a facetime call
with former president donald trump
giving his take on will smith and chris
rock's altercation i always knew hitch
had an arm
back back in pursuit of happiness he's
lugging the the the machine on and off
the subway i thought it was great
you know
they slept in the bathroom in that movie
it's so sad
it's so sick
but it's a sad night for hitch too it's
a very sad that kind of behavior is not
going to help kevin james get a date
with allegra cole i'll tell you that
gerard carmichael made his hosting debut
and acknowledged the elephant in the
room during his opening monologue
this is gonna really blow your minds
can you believe
it's been six days
six days it doesn't feel like it
happened when we were all in high
school like it feels like it happened
somewhere between
jamiroquai and 911 like somewhere
a long long time ago it happened on
sunday
on sunday it's saturday bro
[Music]
then came the reenactment from a seat
fillers perspective this is the coolest
night of my life i mean i'm talking to
will smith
chris rock just got up on stage
hey can i get a selfie real quick of
course yeah
jada i love you gij too can't wait to
see it
hey i'll be right back man
[Applause]
yeah gerard quickly turns from an
overjoyed oscar seat filler to a
horrified one man i love the oscars man
i love movies man i just saw paddington
too you know honestly best movie i've
ever seen i love that little bear man
hey one second y'all keep my wife's name
out
so how about that selfie man come on
no that's okay that's okay and during
the weekend update segment michael che
and colin jost didn't hold back i
understand where will's coming from i
mean you can't expect him to sit there
and watch another man jump all over his
wife without signing an nda
yesterday will smith resigned from the
academy of motion pictures arts and
sciences he wasn't going to but then
jada gave him that look
and it's true e.t can confirm that will
resign from the academy on friday
the decision comes after the academy
revealed they're performing a formal
review of the incident telling e.t in a
statement that they've initiated
disciplinary proceedings which may
include suspension expulsion or other
sanctions permitted by the bylaws and
standards of conduct as for what happens
next for will an industry source tells
et that the board will meet on april
18th to discuss possible punishment
[Music]